this could be magical the only one who  moves well mom and dad dunno and they're  not supporting it at all  neither of them know  [Music]  this stays off to a pretty chilly start  my dad thinks this is such a dumb idea  and it's just not fair because this  could really be the best thing that's  ever happened to me I'm so disappointed  [Music]  this is supposed to be the happiest day  in my life but what if I look around and  like his whole family's there supporting  him and I meet them in everything I'm  gonna be like embarrassed and I don't  want to do this oh and my wedding so to  get this stuff out now it's it's  probably a missed oh man UK and dia hug  give me a smile  [Music]